I've been going through the Cinema Sins fanmail
a little bit.
I don't know if you ever read any of those.
No.
I mean, I see a select group of fanmail.
I filter by keyword so that I don't have to
look at all of it.
And what are the keywords?
Attractive, handsome, awesome, hot, sex, hot
sex, awesome hot sex, free beer.
Okay, so you definitely don't know that there's
a lot of people that want you to do sins on
other content.
No.
Like 25% of your audience is asking you to
do sins of stuff besides just movies.
Like, what do they want me to do?
Like, sins of video games is a popular suggestion.
But I don't really play video games.
Yeah, but, you used to.
Well, yeah, but that was years ago.
Like, is Pitfall still popular?
No.
But that's sort of my point.
Like, you're not a complete newby when it
comes to video games, but you haven't played
in a while, so you bring in no bias, no preconceived
notions, no playing favorites, you know?
I think it might be a good idea.
Well, how would I even do sins of video games?
Like, the experience is different for each
player.
What do you mean?
Like, with Grand Theft Auto, don't some people
play the story mode instead of just killing
hookers and sniping people?
Yeah, I imagine.
Yeah, so wouldn't they rather see sins of,
like, the story mode rather than the ones
I would write, which would be like, "this
hooker didn't have enough money on her after
I killed her" ding, or "this hooker didn't
blow me" ding?
I think they'd probably expect you to play
story mode, yeah.
But I guess I get your point.
You couldn't really call it "Everything Wrong
With" because everybody's experience is a
little different.
It's more your experience of what's wrong
with it.
Maybe you call it "Some Of The Things Wrong
With?"
What else you got?
Alright.
Sins of TV shows.
Hmm.
Pass.
Why?
Do you realize how many episodes successful
TV shows have?
It's like 50 to 100... hours of content to
comb through and find sins.
I am way to f*cking lazy for that.
Well maybe the sins don't have to be so specific
for TV.
Maybe it's, instead of continuity errors and
little tiny discrepancies from one shot to
another you pull out and you do more of a
broad view.
Like if it was Lost you could do all the sins
for the mysteries that they never explained,
or you could do a Bonus Round of Jack speeches
or something.
What else you got?
Alright.
Sins of movie trailers.
I don't know, 99% of them give away the movie.
Is there anything else to add?
Sins of board games?
This game has too many chutes and not enough
ladders.
Ding!
Sins of books?
Reading.
Ding!
Music videos.
How about music video sins?
I don't know, that they exist?
There's not enough nudity in them?
Sins of comic books is one that I see a lot.
Well, now how is that supposed to work, genius?
Am I supposed to rip out all the pages and
scan them so I can get them on the computer?
I don't know, I'm just the messenger here,
alright?
This is what the fans are saying.
Well the fans are sometimes stupid.
Well I'm sure they'll be happy to hear that.
How about sins of YouTube channels?
Isn't that what the comments section is for?
Well you gotta pick one of these.
I don't gotta to do anything.
Okay, I'll rephrase.
You should pick one of them.
This is what the fans are telling you they
want to see, so it'd be really wise to do
one of these.
Alright I guess I'll do video games.
Okay.
Cause then I at least can play video games
again.
Which I haven't been able to do since you
got married and your wife put the kibosh on
my Xbox.
She thought it was mine, man, I'm sorry.
Alright, now let me make it up to you.
I doubt that's possible.
Oh look
I got you a gift.
Great.
A box.
Not just any box, it's a Playstation 3 box.
Why did you get me a Playstation 3 box?
Because there's a Playstation 3 in it.
Right.
Cause that's what we do.
We spend hundreds of dollars on each other
on lavish unnecessary gifts.
There's no con, man, I promise.
I thought you might want to do sins of video
games or something similar.
Cinema Sins Let's Play video or something.
I got you a Playstation 3.
Yeah.
I'm sure you did.
If you don't want it, you don't have to keep
it.
I'm not going to keep an empty box.
Dude.
There's a real Playstation in there, alright?
No there's not.
If there was a real Playstation in here would
I do this?
Apparently yeah.
That was real, wasn't it?
Yeah.
I only told you, like, five times before you
threw it across the room.
You got a spare, though, right?